je pense qu'on peut avoir un débat très
apaisé sur la question des droits
familiaux et leur harmonisation en écho
à ce que j'ai dit à l'instant à Madame
Lubin sur les quatre trimestres
concernant la validation des trimestres
de maternité sans être dans une forme de
caricature ou de procès d'intention il
n'y a pas d'avantage indus et il y a une
situation que l'on peut dire très
calmement aussi et ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il fallait remettre en cause qui est
que la validation de 4 trimestres pour
les femmes à l'occasion du maternité
était pensé pour compenser des
trimestres non travaillés du fait de la
rédactivité et donc de l'arrêt de
cotisation le temps d'élever un enfant
est plutôt à l'échelle d'une année et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où pour une femme qui connaît
la maternité qui est indemnisée au titre
de l'assurance maladie pour le congé
maternité il y a finalement sur l'année
de naissance de l'enfant la possibilité
de valider quatre trimestres comme toute
personne en activité auquel s'ajoute de
valider et de cotiser ce qui est
trimestre auquel s'ajoute quatre
trimestres de majoration et auxquels
peuvent s'ajouter quatre trimestres
supplémentaires puisqu'on dit toujours 4
pour général mais en fait c'est 4 + 4
sachant que les + 4 peuvent être
répartis librement entre les parents
mais qu'à défaut de répartition
volontaire avant les quatre ans de
l'enfant ils sont attribués
automatiquement à la mer et donc on est
dans une situation nous avons
cette différence d'âge effectif de
départ qui s'explique par le fait qu'un
carrière identique du fait de validation
trimestre concomitant à la validation à
la cotisation trimestre par activité il
y a une possibilité il y a une
possibilité nous constatons un départ
plus jeune des femmes par rapport aux
hommes et la réforme telle que nous
l'apportons à la fois par l'effet
qu'elle a et je souscris à la
démonstration sur ce point de Madame la
scénariste Vogel par le relèvement de
l'âge de départ mais aussi par la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme de 2013 amenant
une augmentation de la durée de
cotisation ces deux réformes conjuguées
font que il y aura un rapprochement de
l'âge effectif de départ et que la
différence de 6 mois que nous constatons
avec un âge de départ effectif des
femmes inférieur de celui des hommes de
6 mois va plutôt être autour de deux
mois à horizon 2030 c'est qui m'a amené
à dire cet après-midi que les femmes ne
travailleraient pas plus tard ni plus
longtemps que les hommes même avec
l'application de cette réforme et cette
réforme a aussi des effets en termes de
pension puisque pour la génération 72
qui a été évoquée nous estimons que le
niveau moyen de revalorisation des
pensions permis par la réforme de
manière intrinsèque est autour de 650
euros par an et que 30% de femmes
environ d'assurer femme de femmes
assurée pardonnez-moi auront une
revalorisation de leur pension du fait
de la réforme et c'est justice quand on
sait l'écart de pension que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui